>> Hi, I'm Kathy Calvin, and I'm the CEO of
the United Nations Foundation.
We were founded 12 years ago by Ted Turner
who believed that everyone
can help the UN be a stronger institution,
and help take care of the
world.
And right now we need your help to help Haiti.
The devastation there, the loss, the number
of orphans, the hunger, and
the rebuilding that has to take place is enormous.
The UN is in place to do the job and has been
already making a national
and international appeal for help and funds.
We've been gratified by the number of people
who've stepped up with $10
contributions to $10,000 contributions.
And we need everyone's help.
You can go to the UN foundation's website,
www.UNFoundation.org, and
find out how to text to give or send a donation
or some simply give
support to the UN for the work it's doing.
The next big challenge to going to be reconstruction
and all the
nations of the world need to help get in there
to rebuild the schools
and let the markets flourish and get people
back to work.
So please help Haiti.
We're all part of the same world.
Thank you.